fois c'est un gars qui joue de
l'accordéon qui en jouent sur des
échasses qui est aussi cracheur de feu
qui devient milliardaire et qui va dans
l'espace
l'histoire de guy laliberté a été
racontée mille fois et reste toujours
aussi unique en 84 avec un groupe
d'artistes de la vue la liberté fonde le
cirque du soleil
on ne dira jamais assez comment c'était
révolutionnaire à l'époque de réinventer
le cirque traditionnel on a décidé face
à ces différences à dire autant au
niveau de son éclairage que son son que
ces costumes que sa mise en scène que ça
sa mentalité parce que il ya un esprit
d'équipé 1987
une fois c'est un cirque qui plissent
attentes et qui part en train pour aller
se produire en californie on vise avant
tout un marché nord américain
notre survie en dépend part à cause des
conditions climatiques et c'est au
canada que nous permet pas de tourner
plus que cinq mois cinq mois et demi
aventure hautement risqué la trop pas
assez d'argent pour aller
pas assez pour le retour on a tout misé
le futur ou potentiels ne pas rappeler
nous sommes une soir
le spectacle a lieu et le miracle se
produit les vedettes d'hollywood adopte
le cirque du soleil 1992 une fois c'est
un joueur de poker qui s'installe à las
vegas
guy laliberté fait fortune à las vegas
en lançant spectacle après spectacle et
en concluant des ententes à long terme
avec des casinos le cirque du soleil est
au sommet de sa gloire sans véritables
compétiteurs dans cette nouvelle forme
de divertissement de masse dit la
liberté
adulé comme jamais fonce droit devant un
homme sans peur j'observe en général que
les gens losc atteint un niveau de
succès mais commence à avoir peur de
perdre ce qu'ils ont acquis un
appartement l'un du peintre pas de
perdre ce que tu as acquis mais
l'impression s'est ajouté aux affaires
puis moi j'ai pas pas de perdre ce qu'on
en 2009
une fois c'est un gars sans peur qui va
dans l'espace alors qu'il y à une crise
sur terre guy laliberté se désintéresse
du cirque et consacre une bonne partie
de son temps à son projet spatial
malheureusement pour lui ça coïncide
avec la crise économique mondiale qui
fait chuter les revenus des spectacles
en plus le cirque du soleil connaît
plusieurs revers le spectacle sur elvis
presley par exemple est un échec
constamment se réinventer émerveillé
surprendre et de plus en plus difficile
2010 une fois c'est un gars qui est allé
dans l'espace qui reçoit sur terre une
étoile une consécration qui arrive alors
que s'installe des temps difficiles
opération sauvetage mille des 5000
employés du cirque sont congédiés plan
de relance et d'élaborer pour
diversifier les activités d'entreprises
toute une épopée 1981 une fois c'était
un gars dans une camisole rouge qu'ils
démener à fond pour la première fois à
la télévision
qui aurait pu dire qu'il deviendrait
milliardaire et le premier clown dans
l'espace